das ist wirklich eine verrückte idee auf
dem flughafen der zukunft geht es rund
lukas spezialisten haben jetzt das
konzept für die flughäfen der zukunft
entworfen
wir haben keine grabe start und
landebahn sondern wie ist und wie das
genau aussieht und wo die
schwierigkeiten liegen jetzt hier bei
klick zum seitenwechsel herzlich
willkommen das finde ich wirklich immer
wirklich extrem spannend wenn neue ideen
so komplett mit einer tradition brechen
denn out of the box gedacht wird bei dem
konzept der endlich ran wer also der
unendlichen start und landebahn ist das
genau der fall finanziert von der eu
haben luft porsche ein konzept für den
flughafen der zukunft entworfen und sie
kamen auf diese wirklich im wahrsten
sinne des wortes bahnbrechende idee wir
bauen eine kreisrunde start und
landebahn erst mal verrückt aber dann
doch ziemlich vernünftig auf einer
runden startbahn könnten sie aus allen
richtungen kommen und immer direkt
landen zudem kann die landung oder der
staat kann flexibel an die windrichtung
angepasst werden schlimme videos von
flugzeugen die fast von der piste
gewählt werden gehören dann der
vergangenheit an bei starkem wind kann
immer gegen die windrichtung gestartet
oder gelandet werden denn so
funktioniert es beim fliegen und der weg
ist am kürzesten noch der bau eines
solchen flughafen der wäre teurer als
der eines konventionellen so wäre die
landebahn wie breiter als heute üblich
rund 140 meter das teurer
und dann wäre sie lieber eine
autorennbahn in einer steilkurve leicht
nach innen geneigt dadurch muss weniger
gelenkt werden und die passagiere werden
nicht wie auf einer achterbahn nach
außen wirkt auch das ist eurer und der
durchmesser muss auch so groß sein dass
die lande oder startkurve nicht zu eng
wäre 3,5 kilometer sind geplant die
piste wäre so zehn kilometer lang
auch für die umwelt hätte so ein
flughafen vorteile flugzeuge müssen
gerade in der phase in der sie am
meisten kerosin verbrauchen weniger
strecke zurücklegen werden also viel
spaß am ort auf der lärmschutz für die
anwohner wäre verbessert es gebe keine
einflugschneisen mehr
der lärm für den einzelnen anwohner wäre
also im schnitt deutlich vermindert und
nicht ein ort wäre damit begonnen das
belastet das intresse an dem konzept ist
so groß dass die forscher mit einer
umsetzung von in den nächsten 20 jahren
rechnen
ich finde das sehr spannend also kein
spannendes wieder mehr verpassen dafür
mehr
ein abo aufs auge drücken mit einem
klick und mir dann auch einen auf die
glocke geben bis dann